thank you very much so it is structured
this talk with some questions and the
first and most importantly who the hell
is the sky my name is Alistair Lynn I'm
a software engineer and data minion of
late thread thread is a styling company
for menswear so guys come to us tell us
a bit about themselves style brands they
like that sort of thing and we can give
them recommendations on fashion so this
is clothing this outfit looks advice
it's all pitched around helping people
feel more self-confident this is all
done through a combination of human
stylists and a bunch of machine learning
on the back end I think it's really
quite interesting if anything in this
talk makes you think it's really quite
interesting as well we are in fact
hiring just to clear that out of the way
are there early so please do come and
talk to me afterwards so what is a bee
testing well as with many things with
trendy startups we like to give old
things new names
so a bee testing is your father's
randomized control trials of your it is
exactly the same as the medical industry
as psychology has been using for
donkey's years it is the idea of you can
establish information about how people
behave by splitting people into two
groups a control group and a test group
and comparing quantitatively their
behavior across those two so the way
this usually manifests itself in
e-commerce will often be the surface
level something like this we want to
optimize usually filters ed some
call-to-action button to make people
click through if you're charitable you
will say this is to help improve the
user experience if your uncharitable and
all work in marketing you'll measure
this about how much money you can
squeeze out of people I prefer to think
of this is about building good user
experiences so if we have a CTA on the
website which company says next we might
want to try a few variations of that see
if we can get people to click through it
more
shop now might be long we want to try
like see if we can explain something to
people better I want in like group
mentality thing see if that works
side something a little bit different at
the bottom there and we'll measure
quantitatively how this changes people's
behavior so why might we want to do this
well basically it works Amazon do this
an industrial scale Google do this in an
industrial scale in fact virtually any
big social network advertising company
ecommerce place will be doing this at
scale every centimeter of their user
experience will be tested and tested and
tested to really understand how people
are behaving and to really optimize for
the the user experience so AV testing
can make your metrics go up and make
your stakeholders very happy but more
interestingly to me at least it also
helps you understand your users now the
way to understand how people are
interacting with us um experience the
classic way is to talk to them which is
a very good way of understanding things
and it helps inform you as to watch the
questions to ask ah but there are
problems with this firstly what people
say and what people do are not
necessarily the same thing people will
say they have one experience but their
actual how they behave is not
necessarily aligning with what they've
said and the other thing is there is a
built-in bias here because if you're
reaching out to your users to come and
contact you you're not going to get a
representative cross-section of your
user base coming back the people who
respond to the phone invitations the
surveys tend to be v enlarged your early
adopters people who have had a really
great experience
or people who've had a really bad
experience anyone in the middle probably
not going to bother to respond to a
survey so if you're just judging what
your current user experience is by the
people who are getting back to you
you're not going to be getting a clear
picture of what things are like for the
typical user a be testing doesn't have
that property a be testing is
quantitative rather than qualitative and
is measuring people's behaviors and is
working across all of your users so how
do you do it tough question the thing is
there are lots and lots and lots of blog
posts and talks about people saying a B
test is wonderful you have a B test all
the things here's the great things it
can do for you and here's the ways you
can analyze it but there's not a lot of
time spent on how you actually run it
what are the nuts and bolts because it's
actually quite tricky and most of the
places that I've seen that say here's
how you should run a test basically boil
down to here's why you should pay us
money to run your tests for you such
places may work for you to be clear for
us at threads
they've tend to be a bit too opinionated
opinionated in how to interpret the
results but also opinionated in how the
testing works see the classic tests are
the surface level stuff we want to
change the copy on a page remember
change the color of a button being the
absolute classic it's a little bit
shallow we want to be able to use this
stuff to test bigger things we want to
test changing how we frame something
across the entire site we want to be
able to test swapping in new machine
learning models or strange parameters to
our machine learning models we want to
test as much as we can because we found
it to be a good way to actually
understand what things what effect
things have and that's not really
something that's on option with Google
Analytics is a B testing thing
so we wanted to do it in-house a couple
years ago and whatever our system is at
the time we thought we want these sorts
of conditions we want to be able to
split people such that M percent see one
thing m % see something else we want to
be very sure that my laser point is not
like oh there it is
we're going to be very sure that if
someone comes back they see the same
thing every time if someone comes to a
landing page and sees one thing and then
comes back again and see something
completely different
first you don't know whether to credit
the original thing or the later thing if
they convert and secondly that's just a
weird easer experience you want people
to see a consistent view of the site and
finally we do not want to blow the page
budget sight speed matters sight speed
is a big thing people are very sensitive
to how fast a page loads it is
frustrating to have a page take that
little bit extra time to turn up
that's bad for users it's bad for you if
they're not buying from you it's not a
good thing that slow pages so we want
any testing set up to be fast because
people are sensitive down to tens of
milliseconds on page speed our first
part of this was to just bong everything
in the database thread is a Django
codebase that's kind of the way things
are set up so we'd have a model for any
experiment we're doing a database table
for any experiment we're doing
connecting the user who's getting some
experience with which experience they're
getting which is alright it that
obviously takes linear space in the
number of users you have because you
need a database row for every user which
isn't great needs a database migration
before the test but we can live with
that
it gets messy see the variant which is
either control or test if we were
running running into a test we have this
enum thing should be just a boolean but
it's not it actually looks like this
there's four possible options
see if we're running a test on people
who've just signed up we want to see
whether a particular thing how a
particular thing changes people's
behavior in this case it was a click and
Collect setup we can't sensibly measure
that if we're testing a tiny test group
of new users against a control group
containing everybody who is ever signed
up the behavior of people who have been
on around for a long time will be
different to behavior meaning users past
behaviors are not indicative of present
behaviour you can't it's not a good idea
to have one group massive and longer if
tiny when you try to compare their
behavior so we have this legacy thing so
it's kind of the same as control it will
show you the same user experience as if
you were in the control branch but
they're excluded from the analytics and
then we hack in this extra thing so that
we can put some test users onto the test
branch but have them excluded from the
analytics so that we can actually test
this thing in production it gets messy
and it gets Messier see this is all like
how we decide what someone sees when
they've gone to a page but we need to
decide which branch they're going into
when they sign up and at the time this
is a small snippet of about 200 line
function which ran on users that signed
up doing decisions for every test we had
running on which version of the site
people would see and with a bunch of
extra rules and doing a ton of database
rates a separate database right for
every test that we had life it was a
mess it was ugly
it was slow we had this comment is out
of date because it's an unmaintainable
bunch of rubbish this was not the way it
worked to be clear this worked but it
made us very unhappy so we wanted a
better way and the better way
something like this instead of picking
who specifically gets what experience we
will group people arbitrarily based on
essentially a hash of their user ID into
one of a number of bins for us it's 300
bins buckets and then when with deciding
to launch an experiment we will allocate
that to those bins not to the individual
people this removes all of the decisions
that we need to make when someone signs
up if their user ID modulo 300 is 150
they will get the experience of bucket
150 we don't need to make any other
decisions we don't need to do any
database rights when they sign up it is
fast 300 buckets is a tiny or 300
variants of the site takes a lot less
memory than 3 million variants of the
site for 3 million users we can keep
that all in memory which means we don't
need to be doing any database reads when
someone hits a page so this system is
much faster because it's mule reading on
a memory and we farm all of the stuff
about the testing bit to a separate
service which just worries about running
tests or any of our other infrastructure
does is poke that with the user ID and
ask what should these people see so our
web servers machine learning stuff
doesn't need to care about what tests
are running it doesn't need to care
about the difference between the status
quo and a control group even though the
same same thing it doesn't need to care
about any of these things it just says
what should I show this person and a
service comes back and says show them
this so this still gives us the
repeatability that we had with the old
system the same person will always see
the same thing if they have the same
user ID we can split fairly across the
two users across two branches of a test
but it's got a bunch of improvements
there's no inserts when someone saw this
laser pointer easy useless
I'll go the old-fashioned way there's no
inserts when people sign up which makes
signup fast it's fast on page loads it
needs much work less work to maintain
and it takes constant space in a number
of users instead of linear in the number
of users so a quick demo I did promise
this as I found out yesterday in my
abstract so here we go so we're going to
be testing a ecommerce page which looks
suspiciously like one of bootstraps
example designs and we're gonna be
testing if we can change one of these
buttons to get people to click on it
more so this page is all backed by
jacquard which is our a/b testing
service jacquard can tell you what to
show in this page so all this page is
doing is basically rendering a template
substituting some values a predict in
all the experiment side of that I will
show you in a minute
so jacquard our a/b testing tool is
controls with the command line this is
our current defaults this is the basic
experience people are getting this is
basically key value pairs
the current header on the page says
pricing these are the values the CTA's
we can change the defaults with jacquard
set default my shelf has gone ahead of
me there so if you want to change the
page title to prices we do that it's one
command the page title change the prices
nothing too dramatic there one nice
thing about it is this come online
interface we actually make available
through slack so our product managers
and other stakeholders can poke things
on the site themselves without needing
to go through engineers not the core
part of what jacquard does just to kind
of
handy side-effect so what we're going to
try today is changing this button here
to go from get started to sign up it's
not a particularly dramatic test but
these small tests do add up over time so
first because we are incredibly
risk-averse we're going to not launch it
to 50% of users and possibly see our
metrics tank we're gonna roll it out to
a small number of people to start with
just to make sure we don't get any
horrible requests on the support or we
don't get our error thing screaming at
us we're going to be careful we're going
to show this to say 1% of users so Jack
I can do this Jack can roll out a change
of a setting from thing a to thing B to
a tiny number of users it goes roll out
1% get the new CTA of sign up that then
that's been pushed out this is a
distributed system we've got lots of web
servers almost certainly when I reload
this page they're gonna say getting get
started it was only a 1% chance it
wouldn't but that is now live for 1
percent of users and they will be seeing
that and then we can be like monitoring
all the things to be on a monitor to
make sure this hasn't made anything
explode okay now we might want to
actually run an experiment actually run
the test live 50 percent we used to see
one thing few percent of users see the
other thing for that we need to load in
a definition of our experiment and then
launch it so the definitions of
experiments are all in separate files in
jacquard you can load them manually we
have them in a git repository so they
can go through code review and then
they're launched by CI so the experiment
files looks something like this we have
an experiment ID a descriptive name
we're gonna try a new CTA sign up over
the current get started and then the
branches of this test are there's a
control branch who are getting the
message get started and there's a test
branch we're getting a message sign up
implicitly this is a 50/50 test you can
make it a smaller test if you want this
is going to be 5050
so we then load into the system that
will then ship it off to all the other
nodes ready to launching there is only
one node in this cluster so that's not a
particularly exciting thing and then it
can be launched by us or a product
manager with Java launch however this is
actually going to fail because the
system makes sure you are very explicit
about what you want to do about who is
seeing what the problem here is that we
are saying I want 50% of users to be
moved on to my test branch and I want
50% of users to be moved on to my
control branch the problem is a few
lines up
we put 1% users onto our like hedging
our bets rollout our early group that
adds up to 101 percent and I'm not a
data scientist I'm not hot in the maths
but last time I checked hundred and one
percent it's slightly above 100 percent
that is a problem
so jacquard will make sure you're not
giving conflicting reports about who
should be seeing what so if we now
finish that roll that off we're happy it
hasn't made anything explode we're gonna
roll that back to the default experience
and now we will be able to launch the
test and if I reload this page there's a
50/50 chance that I'll see one ah yeah
it works didn't when I run this through
last time we've now got the different
experience here none of this is
particularly exciting I know it's
changing copy on a button but these
small incremental improvements when you
make them a lot of times can make a huge
difference to your bottom line and
eventually if we're happy that this is
how we want to go we've measured this
people are converting better on this
side I'll go into the measurement in a
bit we might decide to ship it a product
manager might decide to ship it we want
to conclude this
and this is the branch that should
become the new status quo the new zphone
we do that you know the page stays the
same because we happen doing the test
branch and if you show the defaults
these are a new status quo it's all
fungible from the command line and from
wherever you want to hook into the
command line there's a bunch of other
features jacquard can do and it can do
things so about feature flagging if you
want to turn the thing on and off
without running a test on it which we
found about you some in the past
I'm not going to demo all of that today
because I didn't have time to prepare
any of that but if you're interested
it's all documented I can show you if
you come find me so that's the demo of
the tool now I did skip over there very
deliberately how do we actually measure
this we use a very Bayesian approach to
how we understand the data we've got
back from a test so we all set some
prior if we're looking at if we're
measuring the rate of people converting
through registrations so there is of the
people who start a registration how many
will finish it we reckon that's
somewhere between say twenty and thirty
percent that's a pretty broad range if
we don't know any better we'll stick
with that range so a prior belief this
really is awful I pro belief is it's
going to be somewhere between twenty and
thirty percent will compute the
posterior z-- again the Bayesian method
given the data we've had from the people
who have is in the control group given
the data we have from people in the test
group will update that you might say
that this random variable the
probability distribution says they're 95
percent somewhere between 22 and 23
percent and in the test group we're 95%
sure they're somewhere between 25 and 26
percent then we subtract the two random
variables from each other which is
essentially you take the convolution of
the two probability distributions and
what that gives you is a probability
distribution over the improvement you've
got from your test against the control
group
so unlike the more classical frequentist
approach you actually can give answer to
questions like what is the probability
that my test group is better than my
control group or the test experience is
better than the control experience
what's the probability that's worse
what's probability that's better by this
amount what's the expected increase to
some number we care about for our unit
economics there's a lot more you can get
here than you would have in the
classical approach which basically gives
you a decision should you ship this
thing or not we do not set a decision
rule we have no prescribed way of saying
this test was successful you should ship
it against this test was not successful
you shouldn't that is a decision to be
made by judgment of product managers
taking into account how a test has
affected probably multiple dimensions in
how people have behaved and that's
something we've measured here through
the a/b testing system but also taking
into account two things like the ongoing
maintenance cost of one experience over
another taking into account how well an
experience aligns without vision for the
product or our values or our ethics or
taking into account what tests we want
to run in the future there's a lot of
factors that go into our decision-making
on what experience we want to have and
rather than being led by the tests by
having a decision rule which says you
should ship this or you shouldn't we are
led by judgment and we're only using the
tests to understand better qualitatively
what impact it has a different
experience has on our users so our
reporting currently looks something like
this so this is real this was from a
test we ran about a year ago we were
measuring whether something would have
an effect on people finishing
registration it did so what this tells
us is not just this is good or this is
bad
tells us there is where 95% confident
that the improvement from this new
experience it's somewhere between that's
about a half percent
and about 7% median improvement it's
here we can have a look at the actual
numbers across the two branches so where
you reckon the control group who had the
old experience they were converting when
95% sure somewhere between 25 and a half
26 and a half percent at the time this
test group where 95% sure are converting
somewhere between 26 and 1/2 or 27 and
1/2 percent of the time we can actually
look if we really want to at the
cumulative distribution function this is
a bit of a weird one to try and think
about but for instance at this 50% line
that is a 4% improvement which means
we're 50% sure there's at least a 4
percent improvement here or they'll be
50% sure the improvement is up to 4% at
this point here is where the red line
intersects the zero line that's the
percentage chance that the test is
better by some margin or is not worse by
some margin equivalently we're pretty
damn sure this test is a good one
because this is virtually at zero and if
you really want to you can actually look
at the PDF of the post areas they're not
terribly useful to the product managers
but they're quite useful occasionally
for us for debugging whether we've
screwed up the metric so risks of course
there is no such thing as a free lunch
you can't just say a be testing and get
money you have to carefully manage the
risks that come with this the big one is
bias confirmation bias is overwhelming
people will see patterns where they
aren't any our brains our pattern
matching engines this is not a terribly
surprising this is a very well
understood result but people will see
information where there isn't any if we
ran a short test changing the color of a
thing from yellow to blue
and the thing and our report said
there's a 60% chance it's better it
would probably be a good idea to switch
the color that's a good business
decision what it's not is a fact it's
not saying blue things are better than
yellow things it's saying this
particular thing may be better in blue
and yellow for these users in this place
in this circumstances maybe 60% is not
very strong with no data at all it would
be 50% because it would be a toss-up
whether it be one of the other there is
a risk in people taking small results
and going
that is a fact right there this confirms
everything I was thinking when I
launched this test this is now a fact
we're now from all from now and we're
going to make a things this color
instead of this color you can look at
data which is totally consistent with no
change at all and go I'm seeing a hint
of an improvement here hint is a very
dangerous word always be on your guard
if people are saying there's a hint of
something that almost always means there
isn't something but I really wish there
was survivorship bias as another one say
we tested turning something off for a
group of users but a few of our
stalwarts people have been around for a
very long time customers we know my name
get in touch with us we find out they're
on the test branch and they're going I
really wish I could have this thing back
please can I turn this thing back on for
me and we do because we care about users
you know we don't want to cause people
discomfort we want we want people to
have the best experience they can have
we are quite happy and quite capable of
moving someone to having a particular
experience will take them out the tests
are not gonna influence the results all
good do this enough and your test branch
will only have the people in it who
didn't complain that is going to
completely screw up your results if some
of the people in the test branch loved
it and some of the people in the
Ferrante tit and then you get rid of all
the people who hate it it's gonna look
way more better than it actually is
be careful about who you're taking out
of your tests as well as who you putting
into them and finally inertia think of
the massive outcry that happens every
time Facebook makes a slight tweak to
their design people hate change if you
run a test where for a whole bunch of
users you've had around for a while
you're giving them a new experience they
will probably hate you because there has
been a change even if in the long run
that new experience would be better for
them change itself is an effect and
while this isn't a problem if you're
testing on people hitting a landing page
or coming to you for the first time it
is a problem for existing users and you
do need to control for that
and finally ethics a be testing really
is just randomized control trials now if
any of you done randomized control
trials in a medical setting or in an
academic setting you'll know the hoops
you have to jump through to get ethics
approval there's thorny issues of
consent none of that has historically
applied when we've been doing a/b
testing in e-commerce which seems
strange to me I think about ethics a lot
without testing and I really must
encourage you all to consider your own
ethics and what kinds of tests you're
comfortable running before you launch
into running baby tests thank you very
much
I have a question how do you set up the
metrics when you wanted to track the for
example the CTA or something you have to
set up for each test individually yes in
principle we have unfortunately the
actual measurement stuff is not part of
the open source yet I'd like to move at
that we have a library of metrics we
have internally which we can choose pick
from for a test and we can also write
them for new tests essentially writing a
metric is just working out exactly what
you want to measure figuring out roughly
what the values you expected it and
putting with a code to put another
database metrics don't have to be fast
and one last thing when you were talking
about the one percentage of the variant
when you are afraid that it will fail I
don't know if you're if you are familiar
with Stuart frisbee he's a head of
testing in booking.com I'm not familiar
yeah he said a really fun quote you kind
of reminded me and he always says like
don't try new variants on 1% of 5% if
the variance should like fail it will
fail slower so you will see if you test
it like 50/50 you will see the worst
like or the blowout like sure lastly and
so the kind of things we're looking for
here are slightly different this is the
rolling things out for 1% is less to
test like whether people don't like it
will convert slower obviously the more
people you put into the test the faster
you'll climbing's out this is more to
find out is there some bug somewhere
which for some group of people throws a
bunch of errors if they see this text
this is much more it's a little bit
contrived to put that out for a CTA
that's much more important for like
switching a machine learning backend or
something
that's to hedge against the risks of
there's a bug which produces errors
rather
than people behaving differently hey
with the with the priority of setting up
to what degree is the interpretation
contingent on the priors and they made
available to the people making the
decisions afterwards we try and set the
priors to be relatively broad and we
revisit them from now now and then we
don't generally present them as in the
reporting something we may consider as
we try and run tests long enough that
essentially the likelihood swamped the
priors as time goes to infinity that
reprise become less and less relevant
and we do try and run tests for all
tests for at least a week to account for
the seasonality because people behave
differently or different days and after
a week from most metrics for measuring
the priors on that important it is
something you want to get better at the
future just a quick implementation
detail mm-hmm use the hash of the user
ID to make your control and whatever
groups yeah if you run to 1% tests back
to back to the same user IDs get
selected or is it smart enough to use a
different hash function each time the
same user ID will be hashed the same
bucket it's more that when you launch a
thing to 1% of buckets the buckets that
get selected are selected at random so
that will be different each time so
people won't if you won't be unlucky and
always end up in the I'm the guinea pig
groove do you run multiple tests at the
same time and if on the same users and
if so how do you disentangle the effects
of the multiple tests we do run multiple
tests at the same time we hope that if
we're running them on separate enough
site areas for a start the effects will
mostly be
more less independent also if 50% of the
users in a control group are on the
control group some other tests and 50%
are on the contest group with some other
test at 50% of the test group on the
control groups and others tested on the
test group some other tests that more or
less controls for the effect of the
other tests it's not perfect and we have
had problems of interacting tests before
but by and large as long as you're not
testing exactly the same thing multiple
times at once the effects do tend to
cancel out I don't think we have a
fantastic way of reasoning about this
right now but we are running mostly
independent enough tests that we're not
too worried about that
good question I think all right this is
a question more about what aim be
testing in general the way I understand
aim be testing is quite a greedy
approach so you try to constantly
optimize some small details right like
the color of the button yeah so since
you've thought about this quite a lot I
guess are you worried about kind of over
optimizing details and then kind of like
ending up in so to speak in a local
Optima rather than kind of finding the
the global optimum I'm sure yeah
then this is something that Tim Harford
has talked about on a number of
occasions and finally his talks the
incremental improvements can get you a
long way they will never get you to the
global maximum we don't just make
decisions by a/b testing we consider AV
testing to be a tool it's a way of
understanding how a change effect
affects people it's not our overarching
philosophy we don't just follow along a
B tests improving things one at a time
so there's a lot of decision
tomato-based made based on vision and
our vision and our judgment rather than
based on maybe tests and we do take wild
leaps into the unknown every now and
then to see what happens
I just done their last a fixpoint I was
wondering whether you had any examples
of what you might consider or what might
be considered a gray area ethically and
what kinds of a be testing a less
scrupulous company than yourselves might
be subjecting us to it's a little
dangerous for me to speculate while
wearing her with my company's name up
somewhere nearby the tests which worried
me the most tests made thoughtlessly
from services that people rely on a lot
more for I come not going to name names
but for instance companies that offer
ride-sharing services people depend on
those like people depend on them to be
able to get home safely if you are gonna
change something which makes people fail
to get their cab home and get stuck like
in the middle of nowhere that is causing
really severe risks to people if you
screw up Facebook people rely on
Facebook for their for how they interact
with people you know if you make it hard
for people to say they're safe in some
horrible circumstance or any of these
things that these things have real
effects on people they can cause real
suffering there was real psychological
damage the tests where people's
interests are not in alignment with what
you're trying to achieve from the tests
are basically the type of concern be why
I'm mostly pretty comfortable in the
testimony at thread because if we're
making the user experience better we are
helping people dress better we're
helping people feel more self-confident
that's all in line with our mission it's
yeah it's when with a positive result
for the person doing the testing is a
negative result for the people being
tested on that I think we get
interestingly gray areas
just continuing on the example you set
before if people are relying on the
service and you say that breaking it may
actually cause some real problems
wouldn't actually having a be testing
and help prevent those issues from
spreading because if I enable for one
percent then at least it fails only for
one percent maybe it depends on the
nature of the test if you're trying to
do something to discourage piss on
particular group of non profitable
customers from making rides at bad times
that's the reason you're doing the test
is not aligned with their interests if
you're doing a test to say we want to
change these things to make the
experience better for us and we want to
make sure this isn't damaging people I'm
much more comfortable with that it's not
that like tests are always bad if it's a
service that people rely on it's about
the reasons for running a general test
[Applause]